welcome to this video played as a master
ESO call from the United States oh let's
maybe try the blumenfeld again I
recently played this on video against
Grandmaster a book and had a very
interesting entertaining game I mean it
was probably entirely incorrect likes
play but it was really funny and
entertaining to watch I guess so oh ok
interesting
interesting yeah well on age three this
is some cute position of the bishop hmm
d for divorce who has very tricky yeah I
don't know you can easily spend more
time here and I don't want to spend more
falling behind on the clock again and
again let's just stay active hmm
interesting i can take here yes he's got
this idea with queen bee three night of
seven but is this good hmm i don't know
that's interesting check sir let's check
this out Wow
what the heck so what is this means i
can take d 6 knots not so bad then let's
see I wonder the snide okay let's just
prevent 95 and activate all pieces
might be 4i some possibility night
before yeah well why not can go here
some claim takes Knight takes still
fairly iff night here writes very active
position for black maybe night g4s an
issue I can play night before just
winning the exchange and I just looks
better let's look better to me even
preventing 93 as well so should I win
the exchange probably assured especially
because before some basically gone as
well hmm
take it Bishop takes and says some
counter play i don't know but i get i
get all the pawns this may be some
counter play against my king I must be
must be cautious rook a fade it's just a
check though okay so if i get night III
and i have an attack myself so it's um
check if i go night III am threatening
Rooker on the first rank and look
everyone made and Knight f6 is really
just a checksum this should be okay
threatening look on the foot ok check
white resigns yeah yeah this is so quite
like a typical Blumenfeld game if it
works out not saying it was all entirely
correct but just have to play super
actively and hope that it's working out
and mean hope means in blitz chess and
the tournament gave you you should
calculate this interesting many many
ideas look a six also possible I'm not
sure about the move here but it was
interesting yeah the computer gives
white a winner yeah but it's possible
does this surprise me i thought this
this really was was the issue and
computer once to take look cakes and no
95 yeah to be honest what I overlook
this there's also 9 easy
coming oh yeah it's probably just very
good for white and then d for was
mistimed near on probably just your gate
six this this saddle know about he could
give the check of course oops no this
was too much he could after taking let's
just chat again he can give the check
off yeah takes greene takes takes takes
and then it continues i mean at least i
have this quite substantial center bones
I'm not sure if I must take it but maybe
I bus okay it's not still not clear but
why this right is probably better here I
don't know why although this I'm
starting to like four black and so this
is such a bad piece yeah auntie of like
a plug is better yeah he has a hard time
to move really until this is flat-out
winning here I don't know we should be
too
now I have some pressure here quite nice
but it's still not clear should what
what should I do next to improve fire
look group here and tending see three LS
ninety four still very very complicated
all this is just probably lose the sea
can only try to to muddy the waters a
bit but this this is really really dead
lost minus nine quite a lot alright
thanks for watching